hey guys it's Justine and guess what
we're playing Animal Crossing and I had
zero intention of recording this right
now I actually even plan on playing but
I had a nuke miles ticket and I thought
okay it's after 7:00 p.m. so maybe I'll
make it to tarantula island well guess
what no I'm on scorpion island so you
can usually get to be the tarantula or
scorpion island after 7:00 p.m. so it's
like between 7:00 p.m. and 4:00 a.m.
local time I didn't actually think this
was gonna be something that happened and
there's funny events happening so there
he is but he usually ends up going and
jumping into the water but I'm gonna
give him a little hello friend No
shoot I didn't want him to run into the
water so I was just taunting him is this
gonna take me hours so I just want to
like want him a little so he sees me you
sneak he raises up sneak oh gosh it's so
it's terrifying okay we're gonna be here
for a while but here we go again
I've already caught a couple have to get
rid of all this garbage I'm gonna leave
it all here because I am going to let my
inventory know I am getting bit at the
same time as catching one oh wow this is
oh my god can I catch two at the same
time they actually seem to have merged
into one mmm the good part though about
continually dying is they all just
respawn come on now strike how much more
do I need oh my gosh I don't want to
leave my wooden fence it's my favorite
fence I wasn't ready to do this I guess
I can leave everything except my fence
so upset
I brought her milk miles ticket I don't
ever actually expect to make it anywhere
that oh come on you're mine look at that
guy back there he's gonna get me he's
gonna get me he's gonna get me he's
gonna get me he's gonna get me oh my
gosh I have so many of them they're
after me they're after me they're after
me oh my gosh no didn't you see that
skill oh my god it's a talented idiot I
need to see if I can craft this fence
I'm gonna look it up first because it's
one of my favorites
they don't have this simple wooden fence
recipe I came here to collect eggs and
now I'm um
[Music]
choo-choo-choo-choo oh my goodness look
at my outfit ugly friggin mess come on I
didn't even do anything I just cheese
[Music]
yes I'm so slick gotcha at this point
I'm just letting it sting me just so I
respawn and I want to make sure that
there's scorpions available [__] my
inventory is now fools gonna drop
everything so upset about my nook miles
check it goodbye simple wooden fence I
am like having a heart palpitations
because I'm feeling so nervous are you
kidding me where did you even come from
oh gosh there he is there he is and
we're on the hunt again yeah oh dude
jump in the water
I hope there's another one oh oh there
is hello come Chase me
[Music]
it's shocking every time let's make up
as a surprise but we only need two more
and it only took me 30 minutes that's
absurd
and my pockets are full so this is
amazing I'm going to swap it I can't
swap it with my net here it is my simple
wooden fencing
see you later scorpion island see you
later oh we're at how much are these all
gonna be if I were to sell them all
right now I'm not quite sure if I'm
ready to sell them I kind of want to
just hold on to them and think about my
new friends
let's just see what what they would be
mommy's getting a new house tomorrow so
I'm not gonna sell them yet I'm going to
donate one two of my museum he's gonna
hate it
don't want to hear more about it not
quite ready to give them up maybe we
make them a part of the Welcome
committee wonder if you can stack these
I'm so afraid I'm gonna hit release and
then they all are free there anything
better than being welcomed by this yeah
I'll tell you what's better we're
selling them let's sell these and
upgrade my freaking house because I owe
a lot of debt and nothing has really
been accomplished I feel like I don't
actually know how much I have left on my
house I probably can't even pay for it
um I want to sell I'd like to sell let's
do it
shopping I could just pay from pockets
because guess what yes oh thank you I'm
so excited yeah let's talk about my
house I want to expand add another room
I want black it looks good all right
well that concludes today's episode that
wasn't even supposed ever be filmed I
guess I can go to sleep now my wallet is
so full with cash okay well in that case
remember when I said I was gonna go to
bed this game is ruining my life
everyone who definitely is there's no
doubt about it I'm gonna help you out do
as much as possible I don't have a
single belt I can't give you anything
I have nothing I've given you it all I
can't wait to show you my house I have
any
chance to do that yet but this is this
is my outside things are looking good
swapmeet has been upgraded the bunny
event is happening so I've got a very
bloody festive outside I got some
fencing now all it's going well
all right that's it
[Music]